Morgen!
Ich bin bereit für die Expedition
in die unbekannten Welten
in der Schweiz.
Das ist schon einmal
vielversprechend.
Dafür muss das Wetter
aber noch besser werden.
Ui, es kommt noch besser.
Wir gehen zum Flughafen.
Jetzt habe ich nur ein Problem: Ich
habe die Badehosen nicht eingepackt.
Natürlich denkt nun jeder,
der meine Kollegen in der Redaktion
nicht kennt, dass wir Ferien machen.
Aber ich weiss: Immer wenn es
besonders verlockend aussieht,
kommt das dicke Ende garantiert.
Andiamo!
Liegt Mona
mit ihrer Befürchtung richtig?
Oder brutzelt sie trotzdem
schon bald an einem Strand?
In ein paar Augenblicken
wissen wir es.
(Durchsage) Flughafen - Airport!
Die Sendung
heisst nicht "Auf und davon",
einfach falls eine gewisse
Unsicherheit entsteht.
Oh, ich komme zu Ihnen.
Mein Name ist Claudio Zanella.
Herr Zanella, ich bin Mona Vetsch.
- Das freut mich. Ich bin Claudio.
Mein Name ist Steivan Clavadetscher.
Herzlich willkommen
auf der Circle Baustelle ...
Ah, muss ich wirklich ...
... am Flughafen Zürich.
Komme ich zu euch auf die Baustelle?
Wir haben hier
die grösste Hochbaustelle.
Du bist eingeladen,
drei Tage mit uns zu verbringen.
Du bist der Chef
von der Baustellenseite
und du kommst von der ...
... von der Flughafenseite,
der Bauherrenseite.
Das ist eine kleine Sache.
- Eine kleine Sache?
Was kostet das?
Das kostet um 1 Mrd.
1 Mrd.!
Also ich komme mit, ich bin dabei.
Mona Vetsch -
drei Tage auf der Grossbaustelle.
Auf nichts vorbereitet,
aber auf alles gefasst -
das ist "Mona mittendrin".
Das ist dein Spind.
Er ist angeschrieben.
Hier bekommst du nun
deine Arbeitshosen.
Der Gürtel folgt.
Dann habe ich hier
noch zwei T-Shirts.
Gut, also sehen wird man mich.
Also komm!
Das muss ich noch machen.
V.a. dann am Hals hinten.
So hat man
alle Sachen beieinander.
(Baustellen kenne ich bis jetzt
nur von aussen.)
(Und das hier ist auch noch gerade
die grösste Hochbaustelle
der Schweiz.)
("The Circle"
soll den Flughafen ergänzen,
mit Hotels, Restaurants, Läden
und sogar einem Teil
des Unispital Zürich.)
(Die Auftraggeber des Projekts:
der Flughafen Zürich und der
Versicherungskonzern Swiss Life.)
(Tag und Nacht wird daran gebaut.
In zwei Jahren soll es fertig sein.)
(500 Leute arbeiten hier.)
(Für mich geht es zuoberst los -
mit Felipe aus Portugal.)
Hier habe ich ein Gstältli.
Ha, ha, Bergsteigen!
Felipe, gehen wir Bergsteigen?
Nein, aber um die Decke zu schalen,
brauchen wir das.
So kannst du nicht runterfallen.
- Das ist ja wie im Zirkus.
Den Helm
musst du auch noch wechseln.
Diesen Helm musst du anziehen,
der kann nicht runterfallen.
(Ich werde an einen Kran gehängt,
um zu schalen,
Bretter verlegen,
damit man darüber betonieren kann.)
Jetzt mit dem Hammer retourziehen.
Ja, und so!
Ah, das ist egal,
wenn es etwas kaputtgeht.
Hier unten ist ein Träger.
Den Nagel schräg halten.
Man kann es oder man kann es nicht.
Also nie die Finger zu nahe halten.
Du musst die Finger wegnehmen.
- Ich muss noch lernen.
Hier machen wir es genau gleich.
Ja, zwei, drei Schläge.
Normalerweise muss man
zwei, drei Schalttafeln tragen.
Sicher?
- Ja.
Im Akkord muss man das so machen.
Oi, oi, oi, oi, oi!
Richtig Akkord!
Sie schauen schon alle.
Alle 50 cm
machen wir nun einen Träger.
Das ist gut.
Er ist etwas schwer.
Wie bringen wir den rüber?
- So.
So?
Und jetzt?
Oh! Und jetzt,
wie kriegst du den rüber?
Keine Chance!
(Beim Schalen werden mir das erste
und garantiert nicht das letzte Mal
meine Grenzen aufgezeigt.)
(Der Anfang sei immer schwer,
sagt Felipe.)
(Er ist gelernter Goldschmied
und seit 18 Jahren mit Frau
und Kindern in der Schweiz.)
(Er hat sich
zum Vorarbeiter hochgearbeitet.)
(Aber weiter aufsteigen
sei schwierig, wegen dem Deutsch.)
(Auf der Baustelle spreche er eben
fast nur portugiesisch.)
Kannst du mit ihr nach vorne gehen?
- (Ausser mit Hubi, dem Bauleiter.)
* Er spricht portugiesisch. *
Es hat hier
Italiener, Portugiesen, Spanier.
Findet man keine Schweizer,
die das machen?
Das gibt es
sehr selten in der Schweiz.
Wir haben noch ab und zu
Schweizer Lehrlinge.
Die machen nachher aber
meist auch weiter.
Das ist krass:
Die Schweizer steigen alle auf
und am Schluss braucht man Felipes,
die zuverlässig sind,
damit wir unsere Häuser
bauen können.
Das ist so. Ohne sie würde
nichts gehen. Das ist so.
* Lockere Musik *
Hallo, miteinander!
En Guete!
- En Guete! Hallo, miteinander!
Hier kann ich ihn abziehen?
- Ja.
Schau nur, der ist ganz neu!
Schön, nicht wahr?
Noch fast nicht gebraucht.
* Sie sprechen portugiesisch. *
Portugiesisch?
Kommst du nachher hoch?
- Ja.
Bist du ...
In welchem ...
Ich bin im grössten Kran.
Je grösser, je lieber.
Hast du den grössten Kran?
Das ist gut.
Antonio. - Mona. Antonio
ist der im grössten Kran.
Seit wann bist du schon Kranführer?
Lange, lange.
Ich bin ein alter Mann.
Seit 35 Jahren.
Was bedeutet das auf der Baustelle?
Ist Kranführer der beste Job?
Der beste Job ist Polier. Er hat
viel zu tun und läuft so rum.
Am Computer sitzen,
grosse Reden führen.
Aus dem Balkon schauen.
Und allen sagen,
was sie zu tun haben.
Ich bin zum ersten Mal
auf einer Baustelle.
Ehrlich?
- Ja.
Was muss man von einer Baustelle
wissen, was ist wichtig?
Die Arbeit ist anstrengend.
Das ist eine harte Arbeit.
Der Rücken schmerzt.
- Ist er kaputt?
Mit 40, 45 ist er kaputt.
- Sicher?
Aber das ist eben so.
- Ui, ui!
En Guete!
- Danke.
(Der Besuch bei Antonio auf dem Kran
muss warten.)
(Der Baustellen-Chef Claudio
führt mich zuerst ganz nach unten -
zu den Maurern.)
(Vor knapp 40 Jahren
war Claudio selber ein Maurer,
bevor er die Karriereleiter
Stück für Stück hochstieg.)
Nein, nein, nein, hier halten!
- Was, schon falsch gehalten?
Und das machst du den ganzen Tag.
Nein, das mache ich
nicht den ganzen Tag.
Das ist hier
die Situation von jedem Maurer.
Du darfst ihn auch
auf den Boden stellen.
Ich wünsche dir viel Spass.
Du musst heute sehr viel arbeiten,
denn am Abend komme ich wieder
und nehme deine Wand ab.
Je nach Qualität schauen wir,
was wir mit der Wand machen können.
Einreissen oder ...
- Es kann alles passieren.
So?
- Das sieht nicht schlecht aus.
Und wo schmierst du das hin?
Du kannst ihn hochheben
und schön auf die Kante zielen.
(Mein Lehrmeister heisst Lars.)
(Vor zwei Jahren
kam er aus der Lehre,
heute ist er schon Vorarbeiter.)
(Er zeigt mir, wie man einen
richtigen Spatz macht.)
Ist das gut?
Nur noch etwas mehr nehmen,
grosszügig sein.
Ich helfe dir kurz.
Wenn man den Pflaster schon hier
relativ gerade macht,
ist es einfacher,
den Stein gerade zu setzen.
Und jetzt?
- Einfach gerade draufsetzen.
Man kann auch versuchen
mit der Kelle etwas drauf zu klopfen
So kommt er besser.
Und?
Es sieht gar nicht so schlimm aus.
Du hast es nicht schlecht gemacht.
Vielen Dank.
Das ist mein erster Stein.
Ist Maurer ...
Mir wurde gesagt, dass immer weniger
Junge auf dem Bau arbeiten wollen.
Warum wurdest du Maurer?
Bei uns in der Familie
war immer klar,
dass wir alle
eine handwerkliche Lehre machen.
Wieso?
Bei einem handwerklichen Job
ist man sicher gut abgesichert.
Wer hat dir das gesagt? Dein Vater?
- Ja.
Hat er auch
einen handwerklichen Job?
Ja, er hat Forstwart gelernt.
Dann habe ich gesagt:
"Gut, das mache ich."
Ich habe zu dieser Zeit
noch Fussball gespielt.
Als kleiner Junge wollte ich
natürlich Fussballstar werden.
Aha, das ist ...
Er wollte,
dass wir eine Lehre machen
und danach können wir machen,
was wir wollen.
Das war bis jetzt gut.
Es gefällt mir.
(Der schnellste Maurer hier
ist Dusan aus Bosnien.)
(Er braucht gerade mal
13 Sek. pro Stein.)
(Der Akkordmaurer mauert fast
schneller als sein Schatten.)
(Aber davon bin ich noch weit weg.)
(Jetzt geht es los
mit meiner ersten eigenen Mauer.)
So?
* Lars lacht. *
Lach du nur, aber irgendwann ...
Hält er nun? Was meinst du?
- Das glaube ich nicht.
Ha, das verdammte, miese ...
Entschuldigung.
(Der raue Baustellenton hat offenbar
recht schnell auf mich abgefärbt.)
So hält er.
Das Problem ist, dass der Stein
auf der falschen Seite ist.
Nein! - Doch.
- Fuck!
Das käme auf den Boden.
Nein, darauf muss ich
auch noch achten.
Shit!
* Mona stöhnt. *
Wie bringe ich den dazwischen?
- Er ist wieder verkehrt.
Du musst ihn noch einmal wenden.
Genau.
Aber wie bringe ich den dazwischen?
Der ist viel zu ...
So?
Du hast zu grosse Fugen gemacht.
- Das stimmt.
* Rhythmische Musik *
Mit tut schon der Rücken weh.
Dafür schäme ich mich etwas.
Das kann ja nicht sein,
nach einem Tag auf dem Bau.
So ganz entspannt ist es nicht mehr.
Kommt der Chef schon?
Fine-tuning.
* Mona lacht. *
Ja, aber ...
weisst du, ich meine ...
Sie ist nicht schön,
sie ist einigermassen gerade.
Aber es ist meine erste Mauer.
(Nach 4 Std.
ist mein Werk vollbracht.)
Oh, jetzt, Achtung!
Was heisst Achtung?
- Jetzt schaut er es an.
Ist in der Toleranz.
- Kaum.
Ist sie nicht in der Toleranz?
Bei einem Maurer würde ich
das nicht akzeptieren.
Und dann geht es weiter
in diesem Bereich.
Der Spatz fehlt hier.
Ja. - Er ist nicht sauber
abgestrichen. - Nein.
Wenn du genau hinschaust, siehst du,
dass die Fugen ungleich sind.
Der Spatz fehlt dazwischen.
Die Fugen gehen teilweise
offen hindurch.
Hier hast du kein Pflaster drin.
- Oh, oh, ja.
Schlecht gestossen.
Dasselbe hier.
(Ich will die Maurerkelle schon
ins Korn werfen, aber dann das:)
Ich muss ehrlich sagen:
Für ein erstes Mal, vom Bild her,
muss ich sagen,
dass sie wirklich gut ist.
Ich glaube nicht, dass ich
das erste Mal so gut gemauert habe.
Gut, das beruhigt mich wieder etwas.
Aber am Schluss muss man sagen,
brauchen ...
Brauchen kann man sie
trotzdem nicht.
Wir brechen sie nachher wieder ab.
Im Prinzip darfst du
die Steine einzeln wegnehmen,
den Pflaster abkratzen, damit wir
die Steine wieder verwenden können.
(Hier gilt:
Null Toleranz für Pfusch:)
(Mein Tagwerk,
alles wieder zurückbauen.)
(Lars hilft mit.
Er kenne das auch aus der Lehre.)
* Sanfte Klänge *
(Feierabend.)
(Ich übernachte, wie viele von hier,
gleich um die Ecke in Wallisellen,
in einer Unterkunft,
gestellt von der Baufirma.)
(Ich fahre
mit Sami und Alili aus Mazedonien.)
(Ende der 80er-Jahre
kamen sie zusammen in die Schweiz.)
Du schläfst nun auch in diesem ...
- Nein, ich wohne gleich daneben.
Wie viele Kinder hast du?
- Drei.
Drei Kinder - super.
Eine ging
nach der sechsten Klasse ins Gymi.
Studiert sie jetzt?
Ja, und jetzt ist sie neben
dem Studium in einem Praktikum.
Die Jungen sind eine bessere Gene-
ration. Die haben ein schönes Leben.
Wie ist dann dein Leben?
Das ist auch gut. Ich bin zufrieden.
Wir arbeiten, wir kämpfen,
Stress, schnell Probleme mit Alili.
Wenn ein Problem auftaucht,
ist Alili schnell auf Zack.
Auf der Baustelle ist es stressig.
Aber du möchtest nicht,
dass deine Kinder auch einmal
auf der Baustelle arbeiten?
Wenn sie nicht studieren, können sie
auf der Baustelle schnuppern.
Mein Sohn hat das gemacht,
aber er hat Angst bekommen.
Dann haben sie Gas gegeben.
Es ist nicht gut, wenn man sein
ganzes Leben lang, 30 Jahre lang,
auf der Baustelle arbeitet.
(Alili) Jetzt sind wir noch jung,
immer noch kräftig.
Jetzt sind wir hier.
Vielen Dank. Tschau Alili.
Sami, danke, bis morgen.
Schönen Abend.
Ein Bett zu haben - diese Vorstel-
lung gefällt mir im Moment sehr gut.
Noch ein wenig mehr als sonst.
* Mona lacht. *
* Sanfte Musik *
(Hier auf der Grossbaustelle
bin ich die einzige Frau.)
(Auf alle Fälle die einzige,
die herumläuft.)
Morgen.
(Die Arbeit heute: Eisen legen.)
(Mit Pedro, er ist 33.)
(In seiner Heimat Portugal hat er
in einer Schuhfabrik gearbeitet.)
(Eisen legen gilt als der härteste
Job auf der Baustelle.)
(Aber Pedro sagt,
er mache das gerne.)
Dann mache ich einfach so hier ...
Einen nach dem anderen.
Die sind ja extrem schwer.
Jetzt einfach so weiter?
- Ja, immer so.
Immer so weiter.
Sind das die nächsten?
- Ja. Immer weiter.
Machen Sie weiter?
- Ja, das mache ich.
Puh, das ist ...
Möchtest du mit deiner Familie
hierbleiben, ein eigenes Haus bauen
oder wie stellst du dir das vor?
Meine Freundin will das nicht
machen. Sie will nach Hause.
Aber ich will nicht.
Oh, wie macht ihr das?
Wir müssen mal schauen.
Ich muss sie ein wenig ...
Ich versuche, dass sie ihre Meinung
ändert. Aber wer weiss.
Warum möchtest du nicht zurück?
Es gefällt mir in der Schweiz.
In Portugal gefällt es mir nur,
um Ferien zu machen
oder Papi zu besuchen.
Sonst nicht, nein. Keine Chance.
Wenn es um die Arbeit geht,
sage ich: Nein, danke.
Das ist wie Häkeln.
Und jetzt ...
Es ist schwierig.
- Am Anfang ja.
Du musst es so machen.
Noch etwas drehen?
Ja, aber dann probierst du ohne ...
Ah, ah, so! - Du musst es halten.
- Ah, das ist der Trick.
Und deine Leute hier.
Kennst du alle deine Leute?
Ja, fast. Die halbe Gruppe
kommt aus meinem Dorf.
Sicher?
- Die habe ich geholt.
Alle aus Portugal?
- Fast alle.
Die halbe Gruppe
kommt aus meinem Dorf.
Einer nach dem anderen ist gekommen.
Ich habe einen Cousin hier.
- Wo?
Antonio, der Kranführer.
Ah, dort ist Antonio.
Du kannst ihm Hallo sagen.
Antonio, hörst du mich?
Guten Morgen.
Ich höre dich. Come stai?
Molto bene, grazie mille.
* Unverständlicher Funkspruch *
Wie ist die Aussicht bei dir?
Kommst du auch rauf?
Wir kommen dann schon einmal hinauf.
Ist gut.
(Der Job ist hart, der Lohn, im
Vergleich zu ihrer Heimat, aber gut:
Rund 5'000 Fr. brutto.)
* Lockere Musik *
Antonio, vieni qua!
(Antonio bleibt lieber oben.)
(Bei 15 Min. Pause
könnte er nur runterkommen
und müsste gleich wieder rauf.)
Ich will, dass das Zeugs
endlich gemacht wird.
(Der Baustellenchef Claudio
ist auf dem Kontrollgang.)
(Er muss schauen, dass der Fahrplan
des Grossprojekts eingehalten wird.)
Solche Sachen
will ich gar nicht sehen.
Das sinkt alles ab. - Ich weiss.
Er nimmt es nachher weg.
Grundsätzlich
wäre das Ziel bei solchen Sachen,
dass man gut abdeckt.
Sonst lieber die Dachdecker
kommen lassen.
Und dann habt ihr Ruhe.
So geht das nicht.
(Diese Baustelle ist
eine extrem komplexe Geschichte,
eine logistische Herausforderung -
sogar für ihn.)
(Das  Milliardenprojekt "The Circle"
ist das grösste Projekt
seiner Karriere.)
(Und auch das letzte
bevor er kürzertritt.)
Das ist jetzt deine letzte Grosstat.
Ja, das ist wirklich
die letzte Herausforderung,
denn etwas Grösseres
gibt es gar nicht.
Was ist es denn,
was dich herausfordert?
Die Vielfältigkeit. V.a. auch ...
... etwas zu realisieren,
bei dem man am Schluss sagen kann:
"Das wurde einmal gemacht."
Nicht im körperlichen Sinn,
aber ich habe mitgewirkt.
Diese Baustelle überlebt mich.
Es ist so.
(Claudio und sein Team erwarten
heute hohen Besuch.)
Der Architekt aus Japan kommt
und schaut, wie weit sie sind.
Ich treffe ihn gegenüber
beim Modell.
Guten Morgen!
- Nice to meet you.
Nice to meet you. I'm Mona.
I'm Riken Yamamoto.
- Nice to meet you.
Nice to meet you. I'm so happy.
- Great honour. Thank you.
Können Sie mir beschreiben,
was Ihre Vision ist,
was genau hier entstehen soll?
From this side very, very, big.
Von dieser Seite ist es sehr wuchtig
und hoch, ca. 40 m.
Aber wenn man hineingeht,
entdeckt man viele kleine Gebäude
und Durchgänge.
Buildings, very small buildings.
These are different buildings.
In betweenis what we call Gasse.
Ah, Gasse. Like in Switzerland,
these are small streets.
Yes, I learned it: Gässeli.
Gässli.
Yes, Gässli.
Plaza and Gässli.
Es ist ganz ähnlich
wie das Zürcher Niederdorf.
The old part of Zurich.
- That's right.
(Riken Yamamoto will sich
vom aktuellen Stand der Baustelle
ein Bild machen -
zusammen mit Beat Pahud,
dem Gesamtprojektleiter des Circle.)
Ah, nur die Farben hier vorne?
Ja, es ist direkt neben den
Fenstern, darum ist es sehr wichtig.
Wir müssen es prüfen.
Hier haben wir sehr schmale Stützen,
es hat sehr viele davon.
Das sind wie viel Tausend?
- 15'400.
Das ist hochfester Beton.
Sie sind dunkel,
weil der Zementgehalt höher ist.
Riken Yamamoto
findet sie etwas zu dunkel.
Jetzt möchte er sie gerne
hell anmalen.
Wenn man 15'400 Stützen hell anmalt,
habe ich ein Problem mit den Kosten.
Das müssen wir ausbaldowern.
Beim zweiten Gespräch
hat er schon gesagt:
"Vielleicht nur die an der Fassade."
Das sind nun Prozesse,
die wir durchmachen.
Wir müssen schauen, dass es
am Schluss von der Architektur her
aber auch vom Budget her stimmt.
Wenn Sie all das sehen -
wie zufrieden sind Sie?
Sehr zufrieden.
Und das Glücksgefühl
wird von Tag zu Tag grösser.
(In den nächsten zwei Jahren
gibt es sicher noch ein paar Sachen,
bei denen sie verhandeln müssen, um
für alle das Optimum zu erreichen.)
(Es ist 17.30 Uhr - Feierabend.)
(Es geht zurück
in die Unterkunft nach Wallisellen.)
Hallo! Geht ihr nach Wallisellen
zur Unterkunft?
Nein, wir gehen nach Bern.
- Ihr geht jetzt nach Bern? - Ja.
Jeden Tag?
- Ja.
Wahnsinnig!
Jeden Tag.
Aber bei diesem Verkehr -
wie lange habt ihr?
Um 4 Uhr sind wir aufgestanden.
Dann fahren wir nach Zürich.
Wir haben jeden Tag Kolonnen
nach Zürich und retour auch.
Um 20 Uhr sind wir zu Hause.
- Wow!
Was soll man machen?
Hier schlafen ist keine Option?
Nein, wir haben ja Familie zu Hause.
* Sanfte Musik *
* Alle sprechen durcheinander. *
Auf die Finger aufpassen!
Da klemmt man nur einmal
die Finger ein.
Runter lassen!
Gut, super!
Hier?
- Ja.
Jetzt musst du es schliessen.
Uha!
Jetzt aber.
- Dafür hast du den Helm.
Zum ersten Mal bin ich froh,
dass ich einen Helm trage.
Wo ist das hergekommen?
(Wieder beim Schalen.)
(Ich arbeite neben Federico
und seinem Vater Ciro.)
(Sie kommen aus Norditalien
und sind erst seit Kurzem hier.)
Dort, wo ich herkomme,
sind alle Firmen Konkurs gegangen.
In Italien
gibt es keine Zukunft für Junge.
Ich habe einen Sohn, der studiert
hat, aber er findet keine Arbeit.
Er ist zu Hause.
Und Federico?
Federico hat nicht studiert.
(Sie wohnen provisorisch
in einem Zimmer.)
(Ihr Leben hier sei:
aufstehen, arbeiten, schlafen.)
Ich fühle mich etwas entwurzelt.
Es ist nicht schön,
in meinem Alter noch auszuwandern.
Aber ich bin gezwungen.
(Federico und sein Vater sind zwar
zusammen in die Schweiz gekommen,
aber sie haben nicht die gleiche
Vorstellung der Zukunft.)
Ich möchte gerne hierbleiben.
Ich glaube, mein Vater nicht.
Er vermisst die Familie.
Er vermisst das Meer,
seine Freunde.
Er will wieder zurück.
Aber vielleicht kommt auch
meine Mutter in die Schweiz.
Aber ob es ihr hier gefallen würde,
kann ich nicht sagen.
Wir werden sehen.
(Entweder ohne Familie,
aber mit Job -
oder ohne Job,
dafür mit der Familie.)
Kein einfacher Entscheid.
(Jetzt muss ich aber endlich
zu Antonio.)
(Ich habe es ihm
schliesslich versprochen.)
(70 m auf den Kran hinauf.)
* Lockere Musik *
Ich werde fast seekrank,
er schwankt hin und her.
Jetzt bin ich bald oben.
Das ist ein ganz grosses Gefühl.
Die schönste Drehbühne,
die man sich vorstellen kann.
Super!
Antonio!
- Geht's gut?
Ich sagte, dass ich hochkomme.
Das ist ein schöner Job,
eine schöne Arbeit.
Aber ... äh ... man muss schon ...
Kann ich hier stehen, oder falle ich
da runter? - Nein, nein.
Wenn du etwas falsch machst,
putzt du unten alle weg.
Ich muss gut schauen
und gut zuhören.
Ja, das ist eine Verantwortung.
Man hat mehr Verantwortung
als ein Maurer.
(Seit 35 Jahren sitzt er hier oben -
Tag für Tag.)
(Kranführen
ist Konzentrationssache.)
Aber du sprichst doch so gerne.
- Ja, genau.
Du sprichst so gerne
und hast den einsamsten Job.
Wie geht das?
* Unverständlicher Funkspruch. *
Man muss das gerne machen.
Sonst kann man nicht kranführen.
Aber auf dieser Baustelle
ist es streng.
Ich war auf vielen Baustellen,
aber hier ...
Der kleine Kran
kommt nicht bis nach vorne
und der andere auch nicht.
Dann muss ich das Material ...
Ist das bis jetzt
die schlimmste Baustelle?
Es geht den ganzen Tag zack, zack.
Am Abend bin ich total kaputt.
(Streng ist es, aber gleich wie
Antonio sind auch alle anderen,
die ich auf der Circle-Baustelle
getroffen habe,
stolz darauf,
was sie tagtäglich leisten.)
(Und ich bin nach drei Tagen
sehr dankbar,
dass sie diesen Job so gut machen.)
(Felipe,
Pedro,
Ciro und sein Sohn Federico,
Lars mit seiner Engelsgeduld,
Claudio und alle anderen Bauarbeiter
in unserem Land,
die unter Hochdruck an der Schweiz
der Zukunft bauen.
So, Claudio!
- So, Mona!
Herzlichen Dank.
- Vielen Dank und alles Gute.
Danke, dass du uns auf der Baustelle
Circle geholfen hast.
Das ist ein kleines Andenken.
- Vielen Dank.
Alles Gute
und liebe Grüsse an deine Leute.
Ich muss noch ausstempeln.
Den Badge bekomme ich,
nicht dass du wieder hereinkommst.
Danke.
Drei Tage auf der grössten
Hochbaustelle der Schweiz.
Ich gehe, aber alle anderen stehen
ab morgen um 6 Uhr wieder hier -
bereit um anzupacken.